science and research are the
cornerstones to bringing every country
into the modern world I believe that
there is a new opportunity to provide
education for all imagine a world where
all the people work together in harmony
to complete an objective geared to
improving the quality of life for
millions of people there is one thing
one concept that could end all wars a
worldwide campaign against intolerance
people are so prejudiced against race
religion of sensuality it's ridiculous
we need to produce power on a local
level get to look beyond the earth you
have to look space and get serious pot
if you want to have a trillion human
beings they are going to fit on their
tolerance when a man doesn't have a gun
in his hand or a woman for the matter he
or she tries harder to use his or her
mind
a sense of compassion and had
intelligence to work out the solution
you